I'm wondering if we're accepted to be
your employer
that's cute yeah
you interview them yeah yeah yeah that's
growth do we fit your line of what you
see in the future how about that falls
in your core yeah
welcome back to another amazing episode
of the careful boys today we got a
little job interview going on you've
seen him in the background of many
videos this is one of our great techs
here at JK news his name is Tyler he
also goes by a little tall
[Music]
Shake throw that booty in the blender
call the [__] in Ash
love the Luke Skywalker do do you just
go in with a picture Luke Skywalker and
you'll give me this [__] haircut yeah
the skywalking moonwalking you know the
sliding around wasn't there a video
where you already pulled them out here
and did something yeah there was
something right and then I was
stimulating having sex with his mouth
it was something about like white guy
stuff and everyone's like it went some
black guys who the [__] is that guy I
don't know it's when we were berating
him for having an easy life because he's
white yeah let's talk about how
everybody fights to suck my dick off
yeah yeah yeah your mom your mom your
dad yeah very popular reel so you
brought your brother
so Tyler is a rapper look him up under
the name Lil tall he's got music out and
you're on Spotify Apple music YouTube
like any streaming service so as a
rapper SoundCloud yeah I just started
posting on Soundcloud so don't expect
any numbers there that I have you know I
need to get with the top the old times
on that one oh is that is that old now I
don't think I don't think that piff is
really a mixtape spot anymore that's
like Napster dude
I think SoundCloud kind of put that piff
out I'm a bunny boy they're still
probably purists for that fifth I'm sure
he still respected a lot of musicians
like to apply here because Justice was
uh you know he's a musician remember
so um what brings you here to the
interview table
did the job interview episode and people
love it because they're like JK's not
transparent enough and I'm like well
let's try Shady business practices yeah
we're Shady we don't pay people
correctly so why would you want to work
for a company that has such a bad
reputation but at the same time we're
trying to do this we're trying to do
this open we couldn't be transparent but
we can't fix the Shady that's true
that's who we are so we'll just showed
them the Shady toxicity yeah they're
really smart so we're gonna just be
transparent about everything along with
the Shady
um so what makes you want to work at JK
you know I just like looked at the
tables and I felt like we needed some
more like white representation let's go
bro
we got Nick already
I've heard from the fans that we do need
more diversity so thank you for that
we're adding more diversity to them
yeah yeah we need more they meant Mom oh
[__] we need more Hmong diversity I just
thought we didn't have enough Europe
European shades are you Scottish
Scottish American no okay I'm Swedish oh
Swedish there is diversity among just
the two of you yes which explains why
I'm a musician because you know swedes
we've got the pop music you know we're
talking about pop music I always have a
million Melodies In My Head playing all
the time oh good can I hear one of the
Melodies you know Rayna Melody putting
me to sleep I'm just in my dream life is
grounded me very Swedish but I wanna be
here
that's true
all those those peeps no Spanish people
don't isn't yodeling just white people
in nerd clothes anyway yeah I thought it
was like I was like
is it Dutch like yeah all
yeah freestyle you wanna you wanna
freestyle to Bart's drum beat sure go
for it oh you gotta yell though because
you won't be able to hear him his drums
are so loud do it do it soft dude play
it soft play a song please I'm gonna
give you this camera
okay okay all right
this would be crazy
about give him a prompt yeah it's not a
free stop you have to prop yeah okay
just anything at all it's not an improv
show you can freestyle
oh
there you go let's snare
okay how about this
what kind of bee you want like a slower
it's not a freestyle you have to prepare
hey he's very he's a stickler on the
rules
baby
all right pretty good
yo
I switch it up break it down bend it
backwards pull the King Kong hanging
from the rafters yeah I party for the
hell of it [__] super celebrate paint
the town like Rembrandt cruising to
clean the floor like a room but
doing the salsa and Havana Cuba dancing
to the sounds of Saxons and two bus
um
that's a pretty slow beat [__] the [__]
[__] them hard it was good it was good
so what do you think what do you think
he got Timon and Pumbaa all right okay
okay okay patch the musical exam the
musical exam is gone 10 out of 10 10 out
of ten we gotta do the so you can get
the flexibility can you touch your toes
we need it we need a man with sweat spin
dude can you touch your toes because we
got an emergency you might have to carry
people how tall are you holy [__] how
tall are you are you six one I'm six
four six goddamn you guys
[Music]
[Laughter]
so you told me earlier you're not from
California what brought you to
California
brought me to California we all ran away
from California we do we did here's your
Traders how dare you all yeah it's great
are you all from California like born
and raised I am yeah so I'm the only
person in here that wasn't born I'm from
okay yeah you're the only one I'm from
India I'm from Indy
um the reason I came out here is I'm a
YouTuber myself and I literally was like
risen on YouTube for the most part so
you never watched like TV like that
you know I watched like kids programming
and then when it came to adult stuff it
was just YouTube wow and I see like
Breaking Bad in like some of the main
shows oh you you're the part of the
future like for the streaming services
are all [__] and oh I'm the I'm the
disconnects I haven't watched an actual
television in over a decade I'll say
that this is coming how old are you how
old are you 29 yeah so I don't think
tyco's ever watched TV maybe like once a
month at Grandma's house but all this
stuff is streaming on demand streaming
yeah I can't even see I can't think it's
one reason to get TV you don't know the
struggles of a commercial break
I watched him as a kid and I honestly am
like ashamed about how much we used to
waste watching commercials like how much
time I love commercials they're such but
kid commercials were really good yeah I
liked them they were great you don't see
ads all over YouTube oink Zoo Pals that
was great YouTube premium is that why
you don't see that I have YouTube music
how do you watch your sports then do you
watch sports no I watch Dance videos on
YouTube how do you watch sports if you
don't have I'm one of those suckers who
has to get cable but I cancel it the day
after the Super Bowl oh I heard that's a
big problem why what do you mean you
can't do it that they're gonna get hurt
because guys like you yeah I know did it
YouTube just also do a sign like a deal
with ESPN to where you can watch
football games on YouTube now so there
it's not ESPN it's called the NFL Sunday
Ticket they might have something with
ESPN you might be right about that I
don't know but um NFL Sunday Ticket was
you used to have a dish on your [__]
house right yeah last couple years I
started doing a streaming service so you
can actually get the NFL like whatever
your team is you watch your
out-of-market games on Sunday and it's
[__] sick but YouTube just signed and
took a huge deal away from DirecTV
billions of dollars right good get rid
of DirecTV yeah so now but now it's on
YouTube so it's like you can it's more
accessible to students and [__] is it
ESPN that's doing it or DirecTV because
I tell them sync or Swim [__]
evolved with the times it was DirecTV
but but I I don't know maybe the ESPN
has something there's also is it red box
is that the they still exist like that's
what Nikki's are you using it that's the
DVD confidence what's the football one
where you can like watch like all the
games
with the different football videos I've
seen those ones too
like do you really
you can handle this much idiocy in a day
don't don't we strike you as well spend
my whole life on YouTube I'm just is in
this idiocy bubble as you guys are okay
good answer I like that
I didn't know that you were pushing
almost 30 because when you came in here
I thought I was like what is this 18
year old doing here yeah 100 you look
like a young man you look really young
it's good that's a good thing no that's
probably because interesting fact I
don't talk about this online too much
but I'm into dudes so that's wonderful
to keep my appearance up a little bit
more in order to be able to play the
game [__] yeah go get it I hope you're
crushing dude how come I hope you're
smashing
I want to ask you this is it because men
are so they're I mean we're visually
forward right so in your world of dating
it is so important to be that because
you're so much judged by it like even
more so than maybe straight
I mean I would say
as a dude I'm very visual so I'm just
assuming that oh Olive Garden as I am
like I'm not gonna assume that everybody
else is like a super caring person that
only cares about what's on the inside
yeah because it's because I'm full of
[__] you can't come to the insides
because I heard this I don't know if
it's true okay but in passing I heard
that
um bears are like big uh gang dudes have
a harder time in the dating scene
because of that like way harder
you know what I'm talking about why is
it oh because they're it's just so
visually forward like it's it's so
important I was picturing people there
for a second I'm sorry okay my piano
like a bear come with you yeah no no no
because it's like it's so important
Luke's is such an important thing right
because like I mean that stereotype is
for dudes regardless of your orientation
right yeah we're very visual creatures
yeah yeah yeah yeah but then so then if
your partner is like super visually
stimulated then then that means like
um you have to be fit or you have to
look good you have to have like a good
face or like you have to be tall or you
have to be whatever right
is that a true thing in the community
um like it's super I would say the one
thing I don't think it matters too much
is tallness like I don't really hide
really dude scared too much about height
overall oh that's like a girl that's a
stupid chip thing right yeah
is that one of those reasons why you're
gay because you like chicks with that
height stuff
no I
had two no I wish I wasn't gay because
I'd probably get any girl that I want
dude
Crush dude you're right I'm glad you're
not competition with us dude I'm I'm
happy about it no no yeah we're off the
hook he's one of the guys that I feel
like girls look at and find out he's gay
and they're like another one God
I could change him I could yeah I could
pick something and then the rest of us
are like yes he's not competition have
you ever smashed the puss before I have
not never got to beat it up beat up the
little pinky stinky
I've actually had
like when I used to date in and stuff
back in high school early college before
I was like out yeah um I would always be
like no I'm like saving it till marriage
like that would be my excuse and lots of
girls would actually break up with me
because I wouldn't [__] them like whoa
and actually like I've got them damn
whatever it is you got it did you know
that you weren't into them now that way
uh yes but I was taught I grew up like
religious so I was taught that like I
was fundamentally wrong oh so I was
trying to like fight against my emotions
I was trying to do like the right thing
but looking back I don't think I was
doing the right thing I think I was I
think that was kind of an [__] thing
of me to like lights of women in order
to try to fit some sort of narrative
when did when did you know
probably I was like five or six years
old immediately that's what I hear yeah
like you had crushes on dudes you're
just like I have a crush on this this
kid kind of thing that's how you know I
just wouldn't say it all that because I
knew that I like I had the talk that
being gay was wrong at like four years
old oh I am already dang that's crazy
the reason I had that talk so early was
because my like parents caught me like
kind of in like one of those like young
situations or whatever like kind of
messing around oh so like and then they
punished me for it and then taught me at
that time that that was wrong oh and so
like I was given the lesson that being
gay was wrong at a very young age that's
so early get that talk can I guilty
um admit something to you what so like
this target boycott thing I [__] love
it
right because my wife's been so much
Goddamn money at Target and on pills and
[__] yeah then I'm kind of like well
what can we do uh yeah let's do this
let's I'm down what's the target boycott
the target boycott reaping the benefits
of them like celebrating pride month by
having a rack of they had like pride
month in the store remember and then all
these parents are getting pissed about
it yeah like that's [__] crazy that
you have all this rainbow [__] up and
stop trying to indoctrinate my kids and
I'm like yeah there's no more pillows
too
that allowed women bikinis that electric
tuck your penises away or the shirt that
said kids section two so that was what
angered I think parents the most they're
like wait wait so this is for like a 13
year old wait my son's gonna have a
bulge goddammit yeah I better see that
thing
really it's a tech bikini is what they
call it so you can flip your try it
inside of it yeah I'll try it they also
were mad about that t-shirt that said
Satan respects pronouns it had like a
devil on it but it's clearly like it's
trolling it's clearly satirical yeah
it's like it is trolling but you know if
you're hyper religious you do help us
add diversity even more now
it's true yeah pretty diverse now yeah
it's pretty tight because they has ever
had a white gay rapper it's like a
really weird combo isn't it it is it's
pretty great because they they used to
call Eminem that but then he wasn't
actually gay yeah so that wasn't the
same I feel like our team just got a
little stronger it's nice to have six
gay guys
only usually usually five yeah
I question all of you like
so who's who makes your gaydar go off
the most which one talked about the
prostate the most earlier today oh yeah
Nick that's Nick oh wait you knew a lot
about the prostate you know a lot of
people have been talking to me about it
and I know I'll try it once dude
it's not a prostate yeah no I don't
think I don't think I'm brave enough
honestly Oh you mean it takes a real
balls to be gay no I just mean you know
I just put something in your butt it's
like for me I think but if your
girlfriend wanted like yeah what if it's
easy yeah I would be like I don't know
I'd say I don't know I don't think so
well you know like on a good sexual
experience that's what I've been saying
right it's objectively good no that's
what I hear but I'm just like how do you
know you felt it before science my
friend
what do you mean people write articles
about this two-person science or one
person there's a diagram that proves it
I mean Scientific American yeah
one of the memories that I have locked
into my brain you know that's like
crystal clear because sometimes you just
hear phrases and you're like oh [__] you
know what Davey wavy is Davey wavy yes I
do know it was a guest here oh really
we're asking him about like how like sex
is and everything and then we're like
what does it feel like when it's like it
hits your prostate and he goes it feels
like the touch of God see I remember him
saying that phrase and I was like the
[__] is that I mean touch and you know
what I said and then Bart went home and
experimented
as a kid who's raised Catholic I know we
should not be getting that close to God
we're going to stay away from that bro
and no offense to you but yeah you ever
watching Indiana Jones movie look
laughing guess what happens when they
start touching God artifacts yeah their
face melts Arc of the covenants whoa
dude it's [__] crazy I'm not gonna
touch that I don't think I'm holy enough
to touch so how close is he to getting
the job well the fact that he's gay he's
automatically hired because we need to
feel that I said no I would definitely
file for a hate crime
no no because he's smart too
from five other gay guys because there's
already one straight white male that
already like fits that diversity role so
we do need a gay guy straight away male
that try to get me to give them back
yeah
that's great
the framing of that quite a bit
dude that was that would only be funny
if he was straight but now that he's gay
that could be a lawsuit
you better come out right now
then we could cancel that out yeah smart
that's crazy that we need white guys to
bring diversity like that's what the
comments are asking for yeah Monterey
Park baby I don't think people were
asking for more weight no they're not
they're asking for monks baby yeah they
want mongs
um
I think uh aside from that I'm wondering
if we're accepted to be your employer
that's cute yeah
you interview them yeah yeah yeah do we
do we do we fit
your line of what you see in the future
how about that High Falls in your core
yeah honestly I [__] with the vision of
JK news super heavily like that's pretty
cool I like how you guys are just
I like how you don't keep it super
politically friendly you just literally
keep it real like how people talk behind
the scenes like with their that's why we
have to make apology videos every now
and then we like to alienate advertisers
you know why though
see you later I feel like when you're in
a group of like real friends right like
when you're in a like you're Chinese
that crack Chinese jokes or like it's
like if you're if you're if your friend
is gay and you make gay jokes right like
you say it to their face and and it's
funny together right but like now the
world is so sensitive and also it's just
this weird place where they don't even
know your background so let's say I make
a gay joke they don't know the fact that
I'm an ally or whatever the [__] right
and they might just think that I
actually believe what I'm saying like
they don't know that I'm playing satire
so they take it from Face Value they
take it literal and they think that I'm
doing a hate crime or whatever I think
that's that's today it also ruins it
because there are people that are trying
to act like they're doing that there are
a lot of people that are like I'm on the
satire tip with you guys but they really
feel like that that's true that kind of
ruins it for everybody
that girl yeah he's like I'm a comedian
too how come I can't do that yeah yeah
like they butchered it there's a skill
there's prerequisite there's something
else there or like Steve's Hot show dude
I still can't believe you brought that
up and you thought that was [__] cool
because we have your high school what do
you brag about high school you're an
idiot Steve I think you guys are also
just equally you equally rag on
everything like you guys don't
discriminate in who you talk [__] on oh
yeah and that's the thing because like
yeah when you're in your friend group if
your friend's gay you want to do a gay
joke if you're friends whatever you want
to do the joke if your friends Anthony
Lee you want to do a joke you can't
resist yeah I just want to tell you
especially you just want to joke about
how he's Anthony Lee I just missed the
days when we were able to just use slurs
openly
that's what I want now just fingers
crossed we can get back to that place
let's bring back racism homophobia let's
bring out the worst of the worst man I I
miss those days oh my God I was like I
was watching and reacting to a series
that I made with my buddy about 11 years
ago and it was like a pretty big series
online playing through Mario Sunshine
against each other and it's such a
different time because we would just be
like watching it back and there was
times where like I would say something
stupid he'd be like like shut up
like what everyone and everyone's like
oh but like watch it back and you're
like I didn't even like it wasn't even a
thing like yeah right somehow we've
added like so much extra power Behind
these words that was never there to
begin with through time so that now
there's actually so much worse like I
prefer them not being so heated up yeah
like it's better when they're just not
as much tension because then they don't
actually have power now that's a really
good topic actually because I I wanted
it like since you kind of grew up in a
similar era within the same decade at
least right that like we used those
words
on a regular and it never meant like
homophobia in the sense of like like
right so you were called that you
probably called other people that like
did it ever affect you in the way that
like you know I would say well first off
I haven't really been made fun of for
being gay too much maybe it's just
because you know people
don't want to like because you're six
four yeah
six four from Iceland but also it
doesn't it's not a shocker these days
like if someone used those like slurs
against me in a way where like I knew
they were trying to like insult me like
yeah I'd be pissed off even if they were
to install were you out right no matter
what they say so it's intent right yeah
I see but that's me I'm also a very like
lenient open-minded like I get it like I
did not grow up in the more clothes I
just think they're not read by some
people are yeah yeah that's that's the
kind of best way to put it I'm not you
should have said that from the beginning
lead with that some people are are being
recorded
for getting mad at
[Laughter]
and that's what people will say yeah I'm
like no you're are we yeah you know for
acting that one yeah
that's the reason I want to work here
call each other and my my wish came true
I wanted the racist homophobia to come
back it's back that wasn't like a five
minute turn around our ads are but our
ads are gone
the thing is like you you'd use that as
an example to have a discussion with
right and then people will be against
that it's like what the [__] man
you know let those people just be upset
in a room
I know but wouldn't it
their friends say this like when it
affects the business that's what pisses
me off yeah because now we got to
promote lawn fertilizer
we used to get manscaped let's have
lawns in California yeah baby yeah
apparently yeah
lawn fertilizer they still believe in us
because they they're they're with
homophobia Bud Light can't say the same
no wait so does he get the job
I said before yeah the moment he told me
he's gay he's got it
I've been at it